you upset the balance
and now i am here to correct it zondos
your nerdfit experiment has corrupted my
balance
long enough and it must be corrected
the only thing there's time for now is
some chocolate pain
all fit nerds everywhere they're gone
welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina
and this is fitness origins a fitness
competition show inspired by the movies
of the mcu
obviously i have some explaining to do
so i'll just go ahead and bring the guys
in now and catch everybody up
hey guys i
i thought you dusted we saw you dust
maybe a continuity order
uh eric this is an easter egg for one of
your breakdowns
yeah this is like the falcon winner
soldier switcheroo i've seen this before
notice how he blinks and then in the
reverse shot he's wearing a wig yeah
uh no guys come on i'm a scroll
and i have been the whole time the whole
time the whole time
the whole time the whole time the whole
time
okay no no yeah not the whole time i was
just kidding uh just since this morning
actually now
uh since you all went and up the
whole universe of fit nerds existing
i've had to step
in and keep this show afloat but my real
name is
fallows phallus
no fallows is a very common scroll name
and making fun of it is racist
oh sorry also i didn't get dusted myself
because my true form just really let
himself go during this past year
quarantine and uh
apparently i just missed the cut off oh
well done okay so it seems like philip
normally gives you some sort of theme of
the week here and explains how you use
it to inform your workouts throughout
the week we know this week is supposed
to be all about
captain marvel and checking his notes
here okay there's nothing uh let's just
say
uh we're gonna wing it so here's what
we're gonna do i watched
only last week's episode of this show
you've only watched one episode
honestly i'm really only subscribed for
the trailer breakdowns anyway
i watched last week's episode on double
speed and basically i got the gist
you all tried to go for balance you blew
it because
you're all human which i do mean as an
insult if humanity is an insult why are
squirrels always trying to shapeshift to
look like
us don't shame us uh but the one useful
thing that you did last week
is you kept logs correct i
um used an app but yeah i have a pile of
napkins
with my rantings well there you guys go
so you have a record of your own
performance and really
this show has never been about you two
really competing against
each other so much as it is about
competing against your past self
i assume again i only watch the one
episode while listening to an unrelated
podcast
so captain marvel's motto is higher
further faster and that's what you all
are gonna do
i want you to have your logs out and
exercise by exercise step by step i want
you to jump higher
push yourself further take that tempo
way faster okay so that's how you're
gonna grade us on how much
better we do than before no i'm not
committing to any more work than i have
to do
you guys are actually gonna grade
yourselves each day
to see if you went higher further faster
remember it's not about perfection
it's about proving yourself to yourself
so you're gonna actually decide
yourselves whether or not you get full
credit for this week you are your own
judge uh in fact we're not even gonna do
that friday workout thing that you guys
normally do together uh with
philip uh you're gonna do that one on
your own too and you're actually gonna
decide yourself
whether or not you've earned your cheat
meal this week
okay okay all right we're also gonna
move the challenge day to sunday and
i'll see you guys saturday for your rest
day
and you'll let me know who you think won
the week
oh okay okay does this all make sense
yeah i think i got it yeah basically
we're racing against our mario kart
ghost selves exactly yeah
also uh i don't know if that's like
enough for a theme or whatever since
again i've never seen the show before
so let's also say workout to 90s music
all week two
captain marvel style oh pearl jam
i hit all my day one challenges but i
feel like i could have done more
i i felt like i had to push myself
already in that last one and i should
have been
just hitting my stride at that point
what the hell is wrong with me
start to the week it's not going great
so far whatever
last week did kind of i feel like broke
my brain a little bit i'm having trouble
getting motivated for the workout
i was kind of hoping you'd be on a
victory lap but it looks like uh
i'm gonna need a little extra motivation
this week week 11 day two
i went into it knowing i was gonna push
myself do everything double time because
i can handle that then out of nowhere my
my knees started to act up on me
i should be past this i don't know
what's going on this is
really kind of a bummer i'm uh
disappointed in myself but
you know despite all that i i need to
figure out a way to turn this week
around
you know what i'm just straight up
disappointed with myself there's been
past weeks where i was able to do two of
these
and i just feel so guilty and ashamed of
myself
[Applause]
[Music]
after 11 weeks i thought i'd be a
superhero and
i feel like i really disappointed myself
i feel like a total failure i might as
well
just let a scroll shape-shift into me
and live out my life for me because
apparently i've checked out
all right my little human boys
i hate that you call us that yeah it
sounds so weird when you say it like
that
that's what you are little human boys
and wow i gotta say i did have low
expectations but you all
are a very delicate species i'm
surprised you've survived into
what i assume is your 50s yes
yeah early 50s yeah you know what i
really blew it this week
i don't deserve the cheat meal i i
should have done better so just give
tommy the cheat meal
no no no no no no no no no if anyone
deserves the cheat meal it's eric
i was a disaster this week i did
terrible no i guess it's halfway through
the week tommy i was like i'm gassing
out right now i'm just not even aiming
for the cheat meal anymore
eric deserves it he's not after you my
friend i
insist you take the cheap okay okay shut
up both of you shut up just
shut the hell up clearly neither of you
deserves a cheat meal this week
so we just won't have a cheat meal um uh
well hold on
you know one of us has got to get the
cheap meal right
like one one person should get it no you
both just said very clearly that neither
of you earned a cheat meal this week so
why would either of you get it
all right we lied i worked my ass off
this week
actually tommy you did blow it though no
i also worked my ass off this week
tricking you you fool
that's right roll the tape captain
marvel style
oh pearl jam hey tommy tommy don't go
don't go don't go
okay okay i'm still here okay so i know
this is bs like this whole thing if
you're your own judge everyone knows the
real theme of captain marvel is to
question
authority don't believe a word of what
they're telling you
okay okay i won't i won't i'm
questioning my oh wait should i believe
you
no no question everything question me uh
except don't question me
look i don't think that's even the real
philip well it's not
he already told us that oh oh right yes
of course
but this scroll pretending to be philip
it's gonna try to be all
wise like he's going to say that we're a
judge
but it's like king solomon mind games
dude like whoever says that they had a
better week and deserves the meal phil
bishop is going to say
that person is actually the loser of the
week and then the person who says that
they haven't earned
it that's gonna win just trust me i know
how his mind works
okay so what do we do okay so here's
what we do we record
fake vlogs where we pretend to be extra
disappointed in ourselves
all week long and then we show him that
we aren't satisfied with anything that
we've done and then he'll look like an
idiot and he'll probably have to give
both of us cheat meals
oh i don't know if he's going to give us
both cheat meals
oh we'll sit yourself i'm going to crap
on myself
all week long you'll see okay
i'm gonna go above and beyond so every
time it looks like i failed
i will have succeeded trust me because i
got these workouts on block
i'm also gonna be sneaking in some
weightlifting i'm gonna be sneaking in
some runs because i got some new running
shoes
i'm going out strong on this
so you actually had a good week
that's right and that was supposed to
teach me
a lesson of some sort i guess it seemed
better at the time but yeah yeah yeah
great lesson learned i'm gonna stop
responding to exciting marvel related
opportunity ads on scrolls list
also you guys had the reasoning wrong of
this whole thing
like the yes there was a small trick to
it
it was going to be that you both were
going to earn your cheap meals because i
just wanted you guys to have the highest
possible morale
going into this upcoming challenge since
it's the end game challenge so instead
you
talk about yourselves all week long
wait
i talked smack about myself all week
long i don't even get a cheat meal
uh well hey if we do the door dash spot
he has to order us a cheat meal it's the
rules
those are not the rules at all you you
just made that up
oh well uh either way everyone listening
please give it up for our partners at
doordash who have in addition to helping
us make the show
created a special code just for our
audience it's nerd
fitness and it gives you 25 off your
first order and it also takes those
delivery fees you would have been
charged
and snaps them out of existence it just
has to be an order of 15
or more but i mean come on you gotta
treat yourself right
so we've been using doordash constantly
for the cheat meal that we get if we win
the week but also
whenever it's too hard to make something
healthy we can make someone else make it
and it gets dropped off at our door
contactless delivery
all you got to do is download the
doordash app enter that code
node fitness don't forget that part
because one
that's the only way to get 25 off up to
10 value and zero delivery fees on your
first order but
it's also how they know that we sent you
do not
tell your door dash driver that new
rockstar sent you
they don't know what that means just no
one is doing that no one is telling
their doordash driver
i can hear them screaming it outside my
door right now they're saying new
rockstars
sent me just use the code fitness for 25
off zero delivery fees subject to change
and terms apply
okay great here's the here's the truth
of it tomorrow is a very big challenge
and i want you to get ready okay because
things are gonna get kinda weird even
weirder than they have been
you mean like more of the weird lore
that we suddenly have
that's exactly what i mean we know
zondos is gonna be unbeatable with the
full gauntlet
so just know making it so he never had
it
is going to be very important ah are we
talking a time heist
time heist time heist you'll see
but if time travel is going to be part
of it consider going back to last week's
episode and telling philip not to take
his ritalin
right before the shoot because his jaw
was going crazy and weirding everyone
out
we'll try to remember
good luck tomorrow guys you're gonna
need to do some epic stuff if you're
gonna bring back philip and the other
fit nerds
do we need to bring back all of them
well phillip signs your checks so
let's do it all right
it's time for your most important
challenge yet
this one's gonna use every skill that
you worked on with phillip
speed stamina strength seduction
other one i i didn't do them i don't
know but it's gonna be all of them put
together
for this one important moment it's end
game end game
i don't know what that is but we still
have to save philip and all the other
fit nerds and i've seen all 14 million
605 realities and this
is the only way how are we supposed to
do that
well real philip remember scroll full of
real fill up
kind of plan for this as a eventuality
so he partnered with doordash remember
to use code nerd fitness
25 off
and he made it so that those cheat meals
y'all have been eating
each one had what's called an infinity
stone inside of it
that means that every time you ate one
of those disgusting fatty meals
you also were protecting a stone inside
of your body
so you're gonna go back to three
different challenges
smash the hell out of your old selves
you'll reach inside pull out all the
guts and whatever else you were made up
of at that time and hopefully there's
like a stone in there and you use it and
you'll put it all together and we'll
save the day
oh my god wait a minute so if we're
going back in time and killing past
versions of ourselves aren't we creating
like
darkest timelines where we're dead yeah
don't overthink it yeah there'll be
branches maybe you guys will die
but philip will be saved so well how
does one of us win this
win this one's for all the marbles boys
stones
but yes i will be assessing how you did
all week long and then the amount of
effort you give into this and yeah we'll
still decide that
for who gets that sweet sweet door that
shoot all right you ready to go back and
yourselves up sounds good to me and
let's do it let's bring back philip and
all the other fit nerds
get your quantum regulators ready away
you go
wow look at him go
yeah all right
and freeze time yikes i have come
quite a bit of a long way so this won't
hurt too bad too
together guys okay look at you you
probably do your planks modified
it's so warm but it should be warmer god
what is your body heat
issue that's a slimy and something
furry move past me what did
i eat i was cheating this is candy
i'll save this for later why are they
still wrapped
oh wait wait there it
is and fitnessy stone number one
acquired
and
whoever
[Music]
look at you you've kind of tightened up
looked like you're a bit sturdier
i'm gonna take a video of how
embarrassing you are right now you have
to turn the camera around
god i'm handsome it's gonna hurt to do
this but
oh my god that was hard but
i'm able to oh
i ate all cottage cheese
oh okay wait a second all right now this
is great i must have been sleep eating
because there's no way i ate this on
purpose
look i found another in fitnessy stone
so uh
it's a large curd or a small jam
viral comedians yeah it's not as good a
quality if it's front-facing you're not
as good at quality when you're
front-facing
winner freeze time
oh this one is strong um all right
give me those no i want your apples
sorry gorgeous i don't have time
what is this okay uh
is there no food in here it's just gut
better fuel up
yeah it's it's watermelon what's in this
there he is now i'm thanos
is that the movie we're doing all right
got my three stones where is tommy
supposed to meet back like an hour ago
i'll go back and check
tommy what are you doing what gotta fuel
up if we're gonna save the world
you're supposed to just find the
infinity stone not eat your own brains
no if my brains were in my stomach we
wouldn't have the problem that we have
literally how the human body works
so that's very clear do you have the
infinity stone or not
i got it but you already have it
i was waiting for you oh i'm sorry buddy
you want something ask me some of that
all right let's go here we
at this go my secret tom i'm always
sticky
okay that's five out of six uh i just
need the mind stone
sorry eric i don't have it but
there was one behind your ear the whole
time it it's not behind my ear
i'm falling for that again so here we go
okay they're all in remember
bring them all back all of them well
there's a few people we talked about you
can leave all right all right
it's like i was made for this
how are we supposed to get that back for
those mountain climbers man
you know who didn't have to climb any
mountains tony stark
mountain climbers
[Music]
all that exercising and where did it
bring you
right back to me you're going down
zandos
you two think you can stop me
you are not enough to defeat me on your
own
we're not alone on your left
oh hey man yeah we're not alone
this is our fitness origin story rock
stars
assemble
this is pathetic all of you pathetic
trying to be something you're not who do
you think you
are
we are fit nerds
no my precious
[Music]
balance
oh well this is probably for the best
you did it well we all did it but your
part was very crucial
you can rest now but um don't forget to
order that sweet sweet door dash cheat
meal
i'm literally dying oh and we're
literally dying
of hunger chop chop
i feel bad doing this but i just order
it
his login is tommy oh that was your
first guess
tastes good no this is this one we're
gonna pour this one out for philip you
know
yeah i feel bad being so casual but he
did approve a week's vacation for me
before he died so i i felt the best way
to honor him would be to
uh get into my most festive shirt
so you're already moving on it was like
we just got home like 10 minutes ago
look in memory of philip i'm going to
live life to its fullest i'm gonna put
on my
fanciest shirt i'm gonna drink this
sugary coffee and
do what he would have done work
aggressively for 18 hours
well i guess uh what is grief if not
love
per severe eating are you familiar with
the ship
thesis no tell me more i can't
unfortunately i didn't pay attention to
the show
well that's it for this episode of
fitness origins i know somehow we're
supposed to have one more of these
things so
i have no idea what next episode's gonna
be about but tommy and i still have
another week of our challenge so
please make sure to subscribe to epic
hero fitness because the truth is
this whole getting nerds to be healthier
thing is gonna be an
ongoing process and that channel is
going to be where
updates are going to continue to be
happening and not only will there be new
workouts with nerdy themed elements
built into them
it'll also have plenty of other useful
content just to get you
and us a little closer to being in
superhero shape so
for those of you have already joined us
and shared your progress with the
fitness origins you all are an
inspiration too
and we'll see you all next week for the
fitness origins finale
so stay tuned goodbye
[Music]
you